okay let's get started we're going to
talk about optimization or maximization
and minimization okay so you learn to
take a derivative and you know that what
doing what that process does is it gives
you a formulaic way of expressing the
slope of a nonlinear function now you
have a way of expressing the slope of
the nonlinear function well there are
certainly things you can say about
slopes of complex nonlinear functions
but one of the ways in which you use
that information is to determine the
maximum or minimum off that complex
nonlinear function often in science or
in policy or trying to look for the
value of x which either maximizes or
minimizes the function that you care
about this assumes that there's a
functional relationship that is changing
X leads to a change in the f of X or in
the function so there is some underlying
belief and causality some underlying
reason to think that this causality
between X and f of X okay it's not like
the example in your primer where you
might have two variables that are
related but they're not actually
causally related okay so if they are
causally related and you understand how
the slope of that function works you can
use the nature of that slope to
determine the value of x or the value of
the input variable which will either
maximize or minimize the function of
interest okay that maximization might be
local or global
all so here is a convex or concave
function concave function is a concave
function that attains a maximum at the
point s well what's special about that
point s is that at that point s the
derivative of this function is equal to
0 right the slope of the function is
equal to 0 okay a concave or convex
function convex right this is a convex
function and this convex function has
the property that at the point r it
attains a minimum at that point are the
slope of the function f of X or the
derivative F prime of X is equal to 0 ok
so what in both these cases here the
function attains a maximum here the
function attains a minimum the
derivative of the function is equal to 0
ok it turns out of course that if you
have a convex function and it's
derivative is equal to 0 then you're
likely to be attaining a minimum if you
have a concave function and it's
derivative is equal to 0 or it's flat
the slope is flat then you're at a
maximum so concave functions attain
their maximums at points where the slope
is equal to 0 and convex functions
attain their minimums at the point where
their slope is equal to 0 yes you had
raised you
yeah this is this is for a single point
but within the interval that I'm showing
it could be that this is a complex
nonlinear function that goes like that
it'll this this function will still
attain a local maximum here it may not
be a global maximum there may be some
other point where there's a global
maximum but nevertheless this will be a
local maximum and generally you'll care
both about local and global maximum you
know so in with the example of the
carbon dioxide emissions carbon dioxide
concentrations i talked about you are
probably going to care about the shape
of that function near its current value
and not not far away from it even though
some related phenomenon that you care
about might retain a global maximum far
away from the current value of
greenhouse gas emissions if this were a
plateau what you would see would is that
the the tangent line would be would have
a slope of zero at many points it can
certainly be the case that FX attains a
maximum at many points s but they'll
nevertheless be local Maxima okay so it
doesn't have to be a single single point
okay generally okay
okay now so a key piece of information
you have is that to find the maximum or
minimum of a nonlinear function you you
know that feature of that point is that
the derivative is going to be equal to
zero so if you're faced with a higher
order polynomial let's say a complex
nonlinear function or relatively complex
nonlinear function here I've drawn what
it looks like okay but even without
drawing what it looks like I could take
its derivative that you already know how
to do so that's going to be 15 X to the
4 minus 60 x squared you could take that
derivative find the values of x for
which that derivative is equal to 0 and
then you know that at those values of x
where the derivative is equal to 0 the
function might be attaining a maximum a
minimum or possibly a point of
inflection such as this this is neither
a maximum nor a minimum but what you do
know is that if you find the derivative
of this function set it equal to 0 and
find all the values of x for which the
derivative of this function is equal to
0 all those values of x will
comprehensively determine the critical
points of this function critical points
meaning Maxima minima and points of
inflection okay and so
you would what you could do here is you
could plot once you find the derivative
of this did I tell you what that was
yeah so that is 15 X to the 4 that's the
derivative 15 X to the 4 minus 60 x
squared okay I could look at this and if
by graphing this I see that the function
is really interesting between the points
minus 2 and well it's if I if I
determine the behavior before minus 2
between minus 2 and 0 from 0 to 2 and
then above 2 i'll have a good sense of
how the function looks and that's what I
try to do here so I say the sum what I
want to know is what are the values of
the derivative of this function be 4
minus 2 at minus-2 between minus 2 and 0
between 0 and 2 and above two so I could
choose these numbers minus 3 minus 1 1
and 3 plug those numbers into the
derivative so it tells me what the slope
of the original function will be at
those points so this is the derivative
and I evaluate this derivative at these
four different values of x if x is equal
to minus 3i plug minus 3 into that
equation i get 675 if x is equal to
minus 1 i plug it into that i get minus
45 if i plug 1 into that i get minus 45
and then 675 again so that tells me that
when x is minus 3
the function is steeply upward sloping
is that the case yes it's going up
steeply right and when X is 3 it's all
so steeply upward sloping and that's
what's happening here and in between it
changes around for example at minus 1
its downward sloping and at one it's
also downward sloping and I know that
it's zero it's flat okay and I'm just
doing that here okay so here I'm
plugging in the values minus 2 and 2
since I know that those are in addition
to this point zero which is a point of
inflection these are the other points
where the derivative is equal to zero by
the way the definition of the point of
inflection also is the point at which
can cavity changes to convexity okay
what you're doing the way actually even
without the graph what you what you do
is see when you solve for this sorry
that when you solve for when you get the
first derivative you would solve for the
zeros of this function okay you want to
know because of the graph it's easy for
me to tell you that minus 20 and plus
two other points where the slope is zero
but if you didn't have the graph you
would take this equation set it equal to
zero and solve for the values of x where
that was true now this happens to be a
polynomial of degree 4 so it take you a
long time to solve this by hand I would
not ask you
this in an exam but if you plug it into
matlab it'll turn it out in two minutes
two seconds it'll give you the values of
x where this is equal to zero so i would
know that and actually what will do is
it'll give me these three values okay
yes all I'm saying is that I would take
you know I I i computed this derivative
that's the slope that's a function that
gives me the slope of the original
function okay I know so if i put in any
X here this expression will give me the
slope of the original function for that
value of x now I want to know the values
of x for which this expression is equal
to 0 okay well how do I get that I
simply set that expression equal to 0
and I solve oh actually I chosen an easy
example so you don't need matlab to do
this right you can you can tell because
I this is this is the square of that so
that's a nice that's a useful feature so
if I want to set this equal to 0 and
then I solve for x okay so that's going
to be 15 x 4 is equal to 60 x squared
okay i divide both sides by x squared
okay but when you divide
right and this is something useful to
keep in mind when you solve equations I
can eliminate x squared I mean I can
eliminate X to the fourth from here by
dividing both sides by x squared but I
have to keep in mind that there is one
case where which I when I'm not allowed
to divide by x squared and what case is
that that x is equal to 0 because our
mathematics is unable to divide by zero
okay so so I keep in mind that I have to
examine the case that x is equal to 0
and then i divide both sides by x
squared so I get and then i divide both
sides by 15 hmm ok so I this reduces to
a simple equation so then the roots of
this are just minus two plus two and
then I have to look at the case where x
is equal to 0 okay so i must have chosen
that that polynomial so that this could
be done by hand but generally you know
but this is this is a pathological
example most examples won't be like this
okay
ok so this you've already seen if we
have a concave function and it's a
smooth function that attains a maximum
at X star then of course it's derivative
is equal to zero and its second
derivative at that point is less than or
equal to 0 if it's strictly concave then
it'll be strictly negative this was if
you go back to a slide an earlier slide
recall that having the second derivative
be negative was the definition of a
concave function ok so this is a concave
function if it's concave and it's slope
is flat then it's attaining a maximum if
its convex and its slope is flat it's
attaining a minimum ok ok ok how is
everyone doing ok I actually have quite
a lot of examples so we may not get to
the multivariate calculus today but
that's not unexpected we will simply
catch up on it in the next session and
we'll probably be do a little less of
the integration and so on remember we
got to spend most of the time on the
simpler twenty percent of the topics